i hear your timing through your descent
so you don't want to go down and cut
down
is
just touch down
then we start using this
[Music]
okay
that's a wrap try
okay so the next progression
is to get
an inward
front inward position pattern so he has
to tilt
so i get away from my acceleration
throws
okay so my entry is a little different
don't really have to turn around
okay
now i'm going here
you can add your body to it
so these throws where you drop below the
guy are always going to expose you
to
this
okay
so
your timing has to be
of such a nature but you can't get me
out you see because i'm controlling the
elbow you can't get me because when i go
underneath
and he can get me
you see
so my next object
which is why i like the virgin i just
showed you
because i don't do this
and expose the neck
my next object of concern is the other
arm so just like i go under this armpit
i'm going to go under the other armpit
he goes
they're going to go under this armpit
here
and this way if he is trying to get you
it actually helps the throw
so we're just gonna do
this drill now
i'm gonna take the elbow hand off
i'm gonna go under
i will see his hand i'm gonna go under
this
okay let's do it again
you see how close i stayed here
always cognizant of that hand humming
okay
okay we'll give that feeling and you
just
don't enter without being aware of what
that other hand is doing
okay and look to go
inside of it under the armpit okay try
it again so your angle deviation always
has to be coupled with your angle of
deflection so you see that when i put my
left hand here you can't get the choke
can't get the choke you get it
so that's why we're here but then we're
going to slide to the inside i'm
basically going like this
you see it's going to be hard for him to
get that chip
and that's also why
once i start the downward kazushi
so he's going down there's no there's no
more knee right there there's no more
knee you see
now what i have to do
is get the x pattern so
normally you get the x pattern by
pushing the hip
uh
that's not how we're going to do it on
this one i'm going to pull the head
okay
so his foot hits
the inertia takes that leg and then i'm
going to take the head
and that's that little tip back you saw
me do in the angle deviation so i'm
coming in and i go
i'm getting outside that choke okay
so he tries to choke
and it just goes around your head and
brings him more into the physician
okay